[ Music ]
[Narrator:] The physician has always regarded
house calls as a part of his duty to his patients.
And for years, nursing service has been available to patients at home through public health departments
and visiting nurse associations.
[ Music ]
[Narrator:] Physical and occupational therapists, too, have made their services available
to invalids in their homes.
[ Music ]
[Narrator:] Recently, a new member of the medical team has made it possible
to offer more extensive home care to patients.
This is the home health aide.
[ Music ]
[Narrator:] Anyone in the community might someday need the services of the home health
aide.
A typical story might begin here, or here in a hospital.
Before the home health aide begins her job, a referral must first be made by the patient's physician
to the home health agency.
The patient suffered a broken hip eight weeks ago.
Recent X-rays indicate to her physician that the bone is knitting satisfactorily,
and that the patient, Mrs. Lowe, will soon be ready for discharge from the hospital.
[ Music ]
The attending physician informs Mrs. Lowe and her niece of the good news.
But before setting a final departure date, the doctor conducts an evaluation conference on her case.
With him are the hospital nursing supervisor, public health nursing coordinator, social worker,
and the physical therapist who has been working with Mrs. Lowe.
[Doctor:] Do you feel satisfied from a physical therapy standpoint then, that Mrs. Lowe has made satisfactory progress?
[Physical Therapist:] Yes. Mrs. Lowe is ambulating very well with the stationary walker.
[Narrator:] The physical therapist reports that the patient's progress has been good.
But that she will need to continue walking exercise under supervision.
[ Music ]
Since other aspects of her case indicate satisfactory recovery,
the doctor can order Mrs. Lowe's discharge.
The physical therapist is instructed to demonstrate the walking exercise to the public health nurse assigned to the case.
[ Music ]
The public health nurse will in turn supervise the home health aide.
And make weekly checks of the patient's progress.
With the services of the public health nurse and the home health aide available, Mrs. Lowe can look forward to going home.
An early discharge is important to Mrs. Lowe and to the hospital.
Where continuing care is available, the patient can recover at home,
and release a valuable hospital bed for a more critical case.
Here, in the familiar surroundings of her own home,
Mrs. Lowe will receive assistance in her personal care as long as needed.
Since she is over 65, the patient is eligible for Medicare, or health insurance for the aged under the Social Security Act.
[Public Health Nurse:] Well, now since you're over 65 years old, Medicare is going to help you.
[Mrs. Lowe:] Oh, I'm so glad somebody's gonna to help me.
Although my niece helps me so much. Then I have another daughter too that helps me.
[Public Health Nurse:] Good. Well, since you are under Medicare, they help to pay your hospital bill.
[Mrs. Lowe:] Well, that's good. I'm glad to hear that.
[Public Health Nurse:] And in addition, your doctor has ordered a home health aide to come in here and give you daily care
for the things that you can't do by yourself.
She'll be here shortly, and you can meet her. Here's a list of the things that she will be able to do for you.
[Doorbell ringing ]
[Narrator:] The Home health aide is the newest member of the medical team.
Her job is to extend personal care to a patient at home, working under the supervision of a public health nurse.
[Mrs. Lowe:] Yes, I was so glad that you've come and help me do a little of my ironing. My ironing...
[ Music ]
[Narrator:] The home health aide will call on Mrs. Lowe every weekday.
On weekends the patient's niece will care for her.
The niece, too, will do the shopping for food and other items necessary for her aunt's care.
[ Music ]
For the most part, the home health aide is concerned with direct personal care and safety of the patient.
Her duties closely parallel those of a nurse's aide in a hospital or nursing home.
Among these are assisting the patient in using the toilet or bedpan,
and in bathing.
[ Music ]
The care of the patient's mouth, skin, and hair arek also duties of the aide.
But the home health aide is not a personal servant,
and she encourages the patient to care for herself whenever possible.
The patient's bedding is examined daily for cleanliness and comfort,
and changed if necessary.
[ Music ]
While housekeeping is not normally a duty of a home health aide,
she may perform simple household tasks that relate directly to a healthful environment for the patient.
In this case, the aide's duties might include meal preparation since the patient lives alone and can stand or walk for only short periods.
She cannot easily prepare balanced meals for herself.
Hot lunches are prepared daily.
Casseroles and other dishes are made frequently since these may be easily reheated by the patient for dinner.
[ Music ]
Diets are prepared according to instructions from the doctor,
in keeping with the patient's personal likes and dislikes.
While it would be simple to serve the patient with a tray,
the aide urges her to seat herself at the table.
It's one of the many steps towards self-sufficiency for the patient.
[ Music ]
The aide is trained to observe patient condition and behavior.
If a physical problem is noticed or if a patient complains,
the aide is instructed to call the nursing office at once.
The nursing supervisor will contact the public health nurse assigned to the case.
She in turn will report the problem to the patient's doctor.
Here the problem is simple. Mrs. Lowe placed too much weight on her leg too soon.
[ Music ]
In each case, the public health nurse is the on-the-job supervisor of the home health aide.
The nurse, in turn, is carrying out the instructions of the attending physician and others on the medical team.
[ Music ]
The home health aide is authorized to carry out only those instructions which are issued by the public health nurse.
[Home Health Aide:] Good morning, may I see the supervisor?
[Secretary:] Yes. Go right in. She's expecting you.
[Narrator:] Each week the home health aide has a brief meeting with her nursing supervisor.
[Home Health Aide:] Good morning.
[Nursing Supervisor:] Good morning. I've got your new schedule.
[Narrator:] The supervisor reviews the following week's schedule with the aide,
then discusses any problems which may have arisen.
[Home Health Aide:] Well, real well in a way. But she isn't eating too well.
[Nursing Supervisor:] She isn't? Are you having, does she eat when you're there?
[Home Health Aide:] Yes, she eats when I'm there. But she won't fix it for herself.
[Nursing Supervisor:] Maybe you ought to try that business that you did with Mr. Burnside.
When you brought him the TV trays and fixed a little bit of a complete meal on the TV tray and left it in the icebox for him.
Do you suppose?
[Home Health Aide:] That might work real well. That way she can just put that in the oven and...
[Nursing Supervisor:] She wouldn't have to spend time walking around that way.
Might be a good idea.
Make your emergency visits, and you found out that...
[Narrator:] The nursing supervisor holds periodic meetings with her home health aide staff.
Here she distributes helpful printed material,
and can describe new policies and developments which affect home health aides.
[Nursing Supervisor:] Well, what did you think about the book that we used?
[Home Health Aide:] I liked it very much.
[Nursing Supervisor:] Did you like it?  [Aide:] Uh-huh.
[Supervisor:] Did you get a good chance to use it?
[Home Health Aide:] Yes, I did.
[Nursing Supervisor:] I heard you talking about the book this week. What did you think of it?
[Home Health Aide 2:] Well, I think it's very good. Especially this, uh, here with that one patient of mine.
He can't get up out of the bottom of the bathtub when he. ..
[Supervisor] Oh, this is that chair business, isn't it?
[Home Health Aide 2:] She puts the chair in the bathtub as of now,
but she's going to get one of the other ones that is demonstrated in the book.
[Nursing Supervisor:] Mrs. Vaca, you took the book out to your arthritic patient the other day, didn't you?
[Mrs. Vaca:] No. This is the first time I have the book.
[Narrator:] The staff meeting serves as a forum too, where aides can raise questions, exchange information.
[Home Health Aide 3:] Well, last time I didn't get to use these gadgets because the patient I have is an arthritic
and she, I had to get in the shower with her. And put on one of those plastic raincoats that cover your head and all,
and take off my shoes and socks. Boy, that was really an experience.
[Nursing Supervisor:] Well, I'm glad you can laugh about it.
I think some of the new class of home health aides that we're training right now would be interested
in hearing some of these experiences.
They will be soon ready to go out on observation visits with some of you,
and I will be arranging for these with you.
[Instructor:] The public health nurse will be going in first.
[Narrator:] Good home health aides don't just happen.
They are carefully selected and trained.
The advantages and disadvantages, the responsibilities and the rewards of the job, must be made clear.
[Instructor:] With the public health nurse to plan what you can do for...
[Narrator:] The good home health aide is an emotionally mature person.
Perhaps one who has raised a family. They get satisfaction from working with people.
And they are patient and understanding with the sick and their families.
[Instructor:] You would ask her any questions that you would have about the care of the patient.
[Instructor:] Another thing is the activities of daily living to make the patient.
[Narrator:] As training progresses, the student aides are given lectures and demonstrations by qualified members of the medical team.
[Instructor:] Use the long handled shoehorn for a patient without full flexion of his body or full use of his extremities.
It enables him to put on his shoes by himself.
[Instructor:] She isn't having any support here where the bend is in the bed.
[Narrator:] Students take turns playing the part of the patient.
Whenever possible, the demonstration simulate actual conditions.
[Background sounds ]
[Instructor:] To help them walk to a chair...It's best to help them sit on the edge of the bed first so that you can help them get their robe on.,
and help slip on their slippers.
Then to help them slide out and give them support as they walk.
[Another instructor:] Help the patient with their soup. If you dip it up and then run your spoon across.
[Narrator:] With the cooperation of a hospital or nursing home, students can practice with special equipment.
[Instructor:] Now if you'll try one. You don't want to have it too full either.
[Instructor showing slides:] You can see the nurse trying to move the patient over in the bed,
and you can see that she stands quite close to
the bed, has her back quite straight.
In this slide, it demonstrates even more so why she uses this position and the value of this position.
[Instructor holding food:] Or a patient may have cheese. It can be a hard cheese or cottage cheese.
[Narrator:] In an effective home health aide training program, study materials are plentiful,
and students are expected to read and
understand them.
[ Rustling paper and other classroom sounds ]
Students are tested and evaluated during their training program.
Successful completion of a course gives a trainee confidence in herself,
and justifiable pride in what she has learned and earned.
Her effort may be rewarded by a certificate of completion or a badge.
[Instructor:] Mrs. Dishmon, congratulations.
[Mrs. Dishmon:] Thank you very much.
[Instructor:] Mr. Kingman.
[Public Health Nurse:] The man we're going to see now is a stroke patient.
He's progressing nicely now, but you should have seen.
[Narrator:] After she has been employed by an agency, each new aide should have the opportunity to observe work in the field.
Often a public health nurse will conduct this orientation tour.
A lone invalid unable to care for himself is equally unable to care for his living quarters.
[ Music ]
The results of neglect are often unpleasant.
Sometimes shocking.
So one of the first jobs of the aide is restoring a healthful environment,
and the rewards can be gratifying.
[ Music ]
In the past months this patient has made a marked improvement through the teamwork of his doctor,
the occupational therapist, the public health nurse and the home health aide.
A rehabilitation program, guided by the occupational therapist, has enabled this patient to learn to perform simple tasks for himself.
[ Music]
Complete recovery may not be possible for this patient.
He will always require some personal help.
But his newfound self-sufficiency has postponed the day when he needs full-time care in a nursing home.
[ Music ]
[Public Health Nurse:] There's a lady with multiple sclerosis.
We've been caring for her about a year and a half,
and you'll find she's a very interesting patient, really wanting to help herself do as much as she can.
But she has a husband who works during the week and a girl who goes to school.
So, therefore, she's left alone most of the time. We go in and help her.
[Mrs. Dishmon] How long has she been like this?
[Public Health Nurse:] Several years now.
[ Murmuring ]
Though sometimes she can get close enough to the table...
[Narrator:] Not all cases handled by the home health aide involve the care of the elderly under Medicare.
Like the public health nurses, her caseload will vary.
As a rule, a doctor will request the need for the service of a home health aide
when there are no family members present who can give care to the patient.
Fees for home health aide service are handled on a partial or full payment scale similar to fees for public health nurses.
Some health insurance plans absorb part of this cost.
[ Music ]
The aide must understand how much assistance and what kind of assistance to give to the patient to help her maintain self-reliance.
In each case, the duties of the home health aide are clearly outlined and scheduled.
At no time does the aide give care which has not been prescribed.
[ Music ]
The student aide is learning firsthand about these responsibilities.
Soon she'll be given assignments where she'll make her own contributions as a part of the medical team.
[ Music ]
For the others, the work goes on. Often to a happy ending.
Mrs. Lowe, for example, has recovered satisfactorily at home.
In a short time, her physician will terminate the services of the home health aide.
The aide's role has been important.
Providing personal care, the valuable link between the patient and medical care personnel.
Properly utilized, her skills will broaden the availability of medical service and care,
and will give greater scope and flexibility to the other members of the medical team.
[ Music ]
Dedication. Service. Responsibility. This is the home health aide.